let's jump into our next caller from the
405 area code caller from 405 please
identify yourself and jump right into
your question
hey David this is Justin from Oklahoma
City
great I'll just call no absence you're
from South America or Latin America but
how is it that it's predominantly
Catholic and socially conservative but
yet it's always considered one of the
most liberal areas in the world yes so
it's a couple things too combined right
so the Catholicism in South America it
connects to Spanish colonization of
South America and the bringing in of
Catholicism and you also had native
populations that were converted to
Catholicism under different under
varying degrees of duress I think is the
way to say it most diplomatically so
you've got on paper a very very Catholic
continent in South America and in much
of Central America as well sort of to
begin with putative Lior ostensibly at
the same time you and that relates to
some of the social conservatism but at
the same time you've seen significant
more socialistic movements take hold in
South America because of the politics of
the last hundred and fifty years in many
of the countries and the story is sort
of different in each country right like
in Argentina it's a very different
situation than it is in Colombia for
example or whatever the case may be and
you've got this situation which like
I've said before on paper South America
is very very Catholic but like in my
family in South America you have
significant in Argentina there's
significant political disagreements but
their disagreements between the
center-left
the further left and the extreme left
members of my family so yeah I mean I
think you've got to look at the history
sorta to get a sense of what that is and
Argentina in particular with a more
significant Jewish population which is
how my family ended up there as a result
of free and during and post-world War
two
immigration to Argentina because it was
a country a more willing than some
others more willing and able than some
others to
cept immigrants fleeing Europe around
World War two so I mean that's like the
1-minute summary you know okay well
thank you
yeah all right no problem wow that was
it that was a very straightforward one
and we really really have a great answer
got right down to the bottom of it